two days after two mass shootings one
perpetrated by a racist Eco fascist the
other perpetrated by an avowed leftist
the mainstream American Left blames
conservatives for the shootings maligns
half the country is bigoted and
threatens physical violence against
leading Republicans we examine the
profound shame that the left oughta feel
for exploiting the not yet cold bodies
of dead Americans then the usually
correct and usually right New York Post
gets guns totally totally wrong and woke
White's
play audiences of color for fools
finally the Trump administration ramps
up the trade war against China and
that's a very good thing all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
a lot to get to today in part on the
left's reaction to those mass shootings
over the weekend really I've never seen
a worse more shameful reaction to a
national tragedy like we're seeing take
place on the Left right now not just on
the fringes but in the mainstream media
and among mainstream politicians that's
absolutely disgusting and we'll call
them out for every part of it the right
is also reacting in not a great way not
in their condemnation of the left but in
their condemnation of guns we'll
separate fact from fiction at the New
York Post and then the the big story
that no one's talking about because
we're all calling each other bigots and
racists and and blaming each other for
shootings the big story is on currency
manipulation in China and what the Trump
administration is doing to ramp up this
trade war and why it's very important
that we do that we're doing it about 15
years too late but first before we get
to any of that rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer now you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere and you
probably know because I tell you about
them all the time ring does two things
and I'm not sure which is the most
important one it makes you feel safer
because you're connected to your home
from anywhere in the world you can be at
the office you can be in your bedroom
you can be on a beach somewhere if there
is a package delivery you can see and
talk to the package delivery man two-way
audio features if your mother-in-law
stops by you can see that and you cannot
talk to her you can explicitly pretend
not to be home all from your phone that
is thanks to HD video and two-way audio
features on all ring devices I love ring
because you know I go on the road a fair
bit so I'm you know I'm traveling all
over the country sometimes sweet little
laces all home by her lonesome and you
know she's a pretty good shot and
obviously we're armed to the hilt but
still I don't want to put her in that
position where she's got a lock and load
fortunately thanks to the two-way video
and audio features sweet little Lisa can
feel safe I give this out to all of my
friends when they have a housewarming
because on the one hand it's a super
cool product that's the second thing
that's so cool about ring is it makes
you feel like you're in the future like
you're just living in the Jetsons but
also the thing I really like about it is
it's an incredibly good value
you don't have to pay silly ins of
dollars for it you can start building a
ring of security around your home right
now the way that you can do it is with a
special offer on a ring starter kit
right now with video doorbell motion
activated floodlight camera starter kit
has everything you need to build a ring
of security around your home ring comm /
Knolls go to it right now ring at comm /
Knolls you will feel safe and most
importantly you'll feel really really
cool we all know the awful tragedy that
happened over the weekend
one shooting in El Paso Texas one
shooting in Dayton Ohio one perpetrated
by an eco fascist so a guy who has
certain right-wing leanings and certain
left-wing leanings right-wing leanings
say on the nation and preserving the
nation and conserving the nation
left-wing leanings on insane
environmentalism so a rabid
environmentalism and then a racial
bigotry on top of that which doesn't
really cut neatly on party lines that
was in El Paso in Dayton Ohio we don't
know the motive for that shooting but we
do know that the guy who did it was a
fan of Elizabeth Warren he was a
self-described socialist self-described
Satanist a leftist we know that he was a
fan of Media Matters for America one of
the most despicable organizations in the
country he was regularly posting their
content as well I'm not blaming Media
Matters for it because I'm not as
shameful and disgusting as they are
though the left is blaming the right for
all of this I mean totally bizarre
because one of the guys who did it was a
visible warrants of war doesn't stop the
left they are blaming the right for the
shooting they are blaming the right for
Dead Americans they're calling President
Trump a white supremacist none of it
makes sense and it is so hyperbolic in
all of the awful things that the right
has ever said about Democratic
presidents I don't think we've ever gone
this far it's just awful Mika Brzezinski
joe scarborough's girlfriend over at
MSNBC said she actually said this today
the president Trump wants more white
supremacists mass murders that he wants
that that's what he's hoping for in the
country let me ask you something what
has President Trump said that could lead
you to believe that he wants more white
supremacists mass murders anything
anything coming to
of course not it's an outrageously
defamatory thing to say that's a sick
and perverted thing to say about the
President of the United States
especially one who has repeatedly
condemned violence and racism and
bigotry and white supremacy during a
panel on MSNBC The Washington Post's
Eugene Robinson said that we're going to
see a white supremacist 9/11 that's what
he said it's coming up
then mica said that's just what Trump
wants there could be another Oklahoma
City bombing you know it or something
like that I mean we're gonna have the
equivalent of a racist right-wing white
nationalist 9/11 here I think and I make
that prediction you know I don't think
I'm going out on a limb here and there
are a lot of things he can do but he
won't and so you have to ask the
question show and I'll ask you isn't it
okay to deduce that at this point this
is what he wants he is inciting hatred
inciting violence inciting racism if he
doesn't unequivocally call it off and
say this is wrong and we stand together
against this and we are doing this this
and this to help fight hate crime I mean
this is a president who seems to want
these things to happen how else can can
this be explained how else can this be
explained any other way that's how and
the only way it can't be explained is
what you just said at Mika Brzezinski
let's just take a jog down memory lane
all the way back to 15 hours ago when
President Trump made these comments
yesterday on the attack in El Paso in
one voice our nation must condemn racism
bigotry and white supremacy these
sinister ideologies must be defeated
hate has no place in America hatred
warps the mind ravages the heart and
devours the soul warps the mind ravages
the heart and devours the soul we must
unite in one voice
and condemn racism and bigotry and white
supremacy and white nationalism
neo-nazism and I never ever fill in
whatever racist category you want in
there but that's probably the first time
President Trump said that right
that's why Mika knows that he secretly
wants more white supremacists mass
shootings to occur notice she doesn't
talk about the leftist Elizabeth Warren
supporter who shot up a bar in Dayton
Ohio she just I guess that's slipped her
mind even though that's the most recent
mass shooting that occurred on Sunday no
no she's talking about the guy in El
Paso notice she doesn't talk about how
he was a rabid environmentalist eco
fascist no doesn't bring that up she
says he's a white supremacist which is
part of the story and then she says
president Trump wants more of that to
happen she doesn't talk about when Trump
condemns racism she doesn't talk about
just another little jog down memory lane
the many times over the past three years
that President Trump has explicitly
condemned racism bigotry white
supremacism white nationalism every
other form of bigotry just to jog your
memory racism is evil and those who
cause violence in its name are criminals
and thugs including the KKK neo-nazis
white supremacist and other hate groups
that are repugnant to everything we hold
dear as Americans and I'm not talking
about the neo-nazis and the white
nationalists because they should be
condemned
totally we are a nation founded on the
truth that all of us are created equal
we are equal in the eyes of our Creator
we are equal under the law and we are
equal under our Constitution those who
spread violence in the name of bigotry
strike at the very core of America how
many times do I have to reject I've
reject David Duke rejected David Duke
I've rejected the KKK the Ku Klux Klan
from the time I'm five years old I
rejected them I put it on Twitter last
week now I have been asked this question
so many times I have rejected it so many
times oh so I guess from just that
little mashup of everything Trump is
said over the last three years he's been
in politics I mean I could
back further I could go back to when he
rejects racism when he was flirting for
running for president in 2000 I could go
back to when he was paddling around with
Al Sharpton and Jesse Jackson in the 80s
and 90s seems to me pretty consistent
the President Trump has rejected all of
this and mika brzezinski joe
scarborough's girlfriend who has a show
on MSNBC has the audacity to go on
television and accuse the President of
the United States of wanting there to be
more white supremacists mass murders can
you imagine
imagine if a talking head on the right
said that sort of thing about Barack
Obama
yeah Barack Obama wants more black
people to kill white people in America
yeah that's what Barack Obama wants
could you imagine the outcry but it
wasn't just a Mika Micah's gonna get
away with it because no one's paying
attention to Joe in the morning and to
because everyone else on the Left was
saying that too not just her not just a
cable news host the disgraced former
journalist dan Rather used to be a
network anchor then he he reported on
false forged documents about george w
bush's military service just weeks
before the 2004 presidential election I
mean totally egregious act of a
political hack which is who what dan
Rather is dan Rather went on television
he was discussing with Don Lemon and
other fake journalists on the cable
channel CNN why we shouldn't take Trump
at his word we shouldn't believe what he
has repeatedly said for decades about
racism and bigotry we should just
believe what Dan Rather wants to believe
that Donald Trump believes here they are
members of the press
I suggest we were refrained from quoting
the president's words from prepared
speeches into headlines and tweets
without context he sometimes says the
right thing the real questions are what
he does and what he really believes so
you've been watching this all along what
does he really believe you think he
believes that fear conquers that's his
basic belief he's all about fear you
know Don this moment in our history
which I want to make clear I'm here it
was a strong sense of compassion and
grieving
for all those families who suffered in
these most recent shootings but this
moment in history reminds me a great
deal when I was covering the civil
rights movement in dr. Martin Luther
King in the early 1960s
it was clearly definitively right and
wrong that was the truth of the
situation then and now it's the job of
journalists not to try to hide or
obscure but to speak the truth and
that's where we are now
people say well my school president
rumpus racist bull racist is as racist
does I can't read president Trump's
heart but but what he does this is an
amazing statement from Dan Rather this
is an incredible statement from him one
of the most famously disgraced
journalists in recent American history
Dan Rather says it's the job of
journalists as it is the job of
journalists is to report the truth dan
Rather famously didn't report the truth
he reported lies because he's such a
partisan hack that he wanted to swing
the 2004 election and he was willing to
peddle false documents in order to do it
but even on this question what is what
is the truth of this situation the truth
is President Trump has repeatedly
consistently constantly condemned racism
and bigotry for years and years and
years and Dan Rather is reporting the
opposite because he doesn't like the
truth because the truth doesn't fit his
narrative which is false so what does
dan Rather report which is the lie he
reports that it's that it is not the
case that President Trump condemns
racism and bigotry and then he has the
gall to say well I can't I can't purport
to know Donald Trump's heart but racism
is as racism does what does that mean we
know Trump has condemned racism by the
way in politics speech is most of what
you do politics is uses language speech
is politics going back to the orations
of Pericles in ancient Greece all the
way to the present the way that
politicians do their job is by making
speeches is by persuade
their fellow-citizens and persuading
legislators and by persuading the public
with rhetoric oratory and statecraft in
many ways oratory is statecraft so the
very fact that President Trump is
consistently saying these things
constitutes what he is doing even if
there were something he were doing
separate from what he is saying can Dan
Rather point to what that is I mean the
in Rather's idea is that President Trump
is saying we need to condemn racism but
he's doing a lot of awful bigoted racist
things let's name them he's bringing
black unemployment to the lowest level
ever that doesn't seem too big and it
does it bringing Hispanic unemployment
to the lowest level ever uh-huh doesn't
seem too bigoted either he is appointing
ethnic minorities to positions in his
administration okay doesn't seem too
bigoted just as a matter of pop culture
the most famous black superstore in the
world is it endorsing President Trump
were a mega hat in the Oval Office said
I love this guy
that's the same guy who said George Bush
doesn't care about black people doesn't
seem too bigoted to me what else how
about beyond black and Hispanic vote
about Jewish oh yeah he got a town in
Israel named after him
doesn't sound too big so if we were just
judging by the other actions it seems
like president Trump is either the least
among the least bigoted people that have
ever occupied the office no one's less
bigoted than him or he's the least
effective bigot that has ever occupied
the White House I guess he could be
really just so ineffective totally
bungling at the job of being a white
supremacist that's what it is how about
the New York Times headline so the first
New York Times headline was actually
pretty good the headline read Trump
urges unity versus racism now you'll
notice that's not editorial that's not
giving their opinion that's just
reporting on the facts President Trump
speech said we need to be unified
against racism that was the thesis
sentence of the speech so in a very
simple way and just here's the facts
that's what the speech did good headline
left was furious about it they were so
angry because there ain't their angry
that reality is not comporting to what
they want the narrative to be they would
have much preferred if Trump went out
and said wahoo we love white supremacy
yeah Hitler forever
all right let's war now that's what they
imagine President Trump to be doing and
that's the lie they're peddling to the
American people so when reality doesn't
jibe with their stupid bigoted narrative
they have to change the reality so it
even Nate Silver who's a leftist usually
is one of the more reasonable leftists
Nate Silver is the statistician 538 he
tweets out quote not sure Trump urges
unity versus racism is how I would have
framed the story right you would have
framed it with a lie if that's not how
you would have framed the story than you
would have framed it with a lie I guess
because if you frame it with the truth
that's what the story says cory booker
senator spartacus crying tears of rage
over his own dwindling poll numbers
tweeted out quote lives literally depend
on you doing better new york times
please do I was trying to get my tears
of Rage Spartacus voice their lives
literally depend on you doing better New
York Times please do the New York Times
headline is gonna kill people
now talk about a little emotional
manipulation talk about a threat to the
New York Times say hey New York Times if
you don't report the lies that are
politically convenient to me that I want
you to use I'm gonna accuse you of
killing people Cory Booker very serious
man
totally serious Spartacus candidate for
president then we have aoc the PS de la
resistance quote let this front page
serve as a reminder of how white
supremacy is aided by and often relies
upon the cowardice of mainstream
institutions the New York Times is now
an organ of white supremacy you've seen
this creep up in the last year or two
the the old word that the left would be
responsibly and recklessly used to smear
everyone they don't like was racist now
they're they're turning it up to 11
they're turning it up a notch and
they're saying anyone who disagrees with
them is a white supremacist including
now apparently the New York Times that's
it so this is pretty unfortunate because
there are genuinely bigots out there
which I'm more than happy to ostracize
and
and point out that they're bigots and
say therefore we shouldn't listen to
them or take them seriously when you use
the phrase racism white nationalism
white supremacy whatever phrase you want
to use to describe everybody it loses
its meaning so you actually can no
longer use it to describe even people
that it would accurately describe
because it doesn't have meaning the left
has robbed it of meaning another reason
that they should feel profound shame and
their handling of this story so what did
the New York Times do did they keep the
headline all the news that's fit to
print the great lady the the standard of
journalism in the world no of course not
they capitulated to the left how could
they not it's their whole audience it's
their whole editorial board and they
they're being threatened by the left I
mean cory booker said that will accuse
you of killing people if you don't
change the headline so they changed the
headline to a sailing hate but not guns
right uh-huh we'll get into why in a
second because the right is getting this
a little bit wrong too but first you
know look you can say the New York Times
is totally gone overboard the New York
Times is a former newspaper like drew
calls them you can say that the cable
news networks MSNBC and CNN are a joke
they're nothing but Pravda trash for
leftist cosplayers and LARPers who want
to pretend that we're living in the
1930s Germany even though when you look
outside at the facts obviously you the
human condition is broken
obviously there are tragedies that are
going to happen and they'll they've
happened in the past and they're gonna
happen in the future but broadly
speaking everything's going pretty well
even Network News which is supposed to
be more moderate stal worked more sober
this is the mainstream that's going out
to way more people in the country even
Network News NBC News Network not cable
accused President Trump of inspiring
mass murderers here they are we found
the ideology that can inspire some to
mass murder is taking inspiration from
the president we went to a neo-nazi
first of all in Germany a few weeks ago
but what surprised us most is what
organizers were handing out at the door
so they're giving out hats mgh a make
Germany hate again we found the man who
made the Hat so people are using his yes
his hats yeah
inspiration yes do people here like him
do you like it I like his style
NBC News had so much trouble linking
President Trump to white supremacists
and bigots and racists
in America they had to fly all the way
over the Atlantic Ocean they had to go
to Germany they had to find some random
festival somewhere they had to pick up a
Red Hat that was totally changed to
become a parody of the make America
great again hat wasn't great it was hate
said make Germany hate again so it
wasn't saying we were going to model
ourselves after the Trump movement he
was saying we're going to take the Trump
movement and invert it right not great
but hate to they had they had to go all
the way over there to tie president
Trump to this kind of bigotry then they
say they said do you like Trump and they
said well I like his style yeah they
like the style they like the Hat they
don't like what he's doing they don't
like what he's saying they don't like
his policies but they like you know that
breaking news report we found a team
that flew to Germany to find a festival
where the people liked red hats
NBC News also that they can say the
Trump inspires neo-nazis and mass
murderers then the phrase on Twitter
Massacre Moscow mich started to trend
their quote these are people who refer
to Mitch McConnell as moscow Mitch
because they they can't get over that
ridiculous conspiracy that President
Trump is a puppet of the Russian
government even though even even Bob
Muller totally disproved that in his
Mulder report even though you would
think the more educated Democrats maybe
I'm maybe I'm using a phrase that's a
contradiction in terms you would think
they would get over that hoax after
three years they haven't so massacre
Moscow Mitch slaughter the Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell was
trending on
and I wouldn't even bring it up because
Twitter is not real life I've said this
many times Twitter is not real life
however it wasn't just the wacky
anonymous accounts that were tweeting
him it was CNN contributors CNN
contributor why jihad alley I don't know
how to pronounce his name because I
don't know who he is because I don't
watch CNN but he is a CNN contributor
why jihad alley tweeted out quote
massacre Moscow mich is trending I still
have faith in America imagine if a Fox
contributor in 2011 tweeted out Massacre
Barack Obama is trending I have faith in
America imagine what would happen the
guy would probably be arrested but
what's happened to this guy watch a hot
alley as of now nothing he tweets us
about Mitch McConnell right now Mitch
McConnell is at his home recovering from
a shoulder injury because he fell
because he's got weak legs because he's
a a recovery and victim of polio in his
youth a lot of people don't know that
about Mitch McConnell but he had polio
so how did the left treat him why of
course a mob showed up outside his house
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's a mob in the middle of the night
outside the home of the elderly Senate
Majority Leader pollo polio victim
recovering from a shoulder injury
because of children he's kidnapping I
guess that refers to the fact that we
arrest illegal aliens and this myth that
we're keeping children in cages using
photos that actually are from the Obama
administration that's the left for you
and then my favorite one risa Aslan
who's a former CNN contributor and an
admitted cannibal actual cannibal
actually eight human brains on camera he
came out and called for the murder of
Kelly and Conway the senior advisor to
the president we'll get to that in a
second we'll get to what this means for
the left we will get to a really
terrible editorial from the New York
Post usually right usually conservative
they've gone totally bonkers on guns and
then really we'll get to the most
important story which is China's
currency manipulation of what we're
doing to combat it but first I've got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube go
to daily wire comm ten bucks a month 100
dollars for an annual membership you get
me you get the under Clavin show you get
the Ben Shapiro show you get the Matt
Walsh show you have to ask questions in
the mailbag coming up on Thursday you
ask questions backstage you get
everything you get to watch the last ten
minutes of my Sunday special interview
with Ben Shapiro I have to thank all of
you for going over and listening to it
numbers are doing really well it charted
at I think number six on the overall
worldwide Apple podcasts charts you can
check that out on the Ben Shapiro show
RSS feed and podcast feed and it was a
lot of fun to sit down with Ben so
please go over there and look also
because if we get it to trend higher
then we'll have to have me back on and
that will make him very sad and it will
make me giggle so God go over there go
to daily wire calm we'll be right back
with a lot more
finally this is the little cherry on top
of this hate-filled sundae from the left
reacting to a national tragedy and
blaming the right for it with no base
whatsoever
former CNN contributor and admitted
cannibal Risa a slam called for the
murder of the senior advisor to the
president
Kellyanne Conway he tweeted out quote
you are the depraved evil we need to
eradicate because Kelly and Conway said
we need to eradicate depraved evil
obviously that's what we all want to do
evil doesn't have a political party the
shooter in Texas might have been a
little more right-wing
maybe say he's very left-wing too but
even let's just say he was a little more
right-wing the shooter in Ohio was
obviously very left-wing
evil doesn't have a political party we
need to eradicate evil and he riesling
responded to that by saying we need to
eradicate you you didn't say we need to
eradicate you from office didn't say we
need to eradicate you from politics said
we need to eradicate you we need to
murder you imagine imagine if someone a
conservative tweeted out about a senior
advisor to Barack Obama we need to kill
you we need to eradicate you Roseanne
Barr once tweeted out a racially
insensitive joke about the senior
advisor to President Obama Valerie
Jarrett she lost her hit sitcom within
hours this guy CNN contributor Risa
Ashland calls to murder the senior
advisor to the president and what has
happened nothing this in a situation
where one of the shooters is an admitted
socialist and Liz Warren supporter but
the left doesn't care they don't report
on it they blame the right for
everything they call the right bigoted
no introspection no humility no grace
they just pretend that they're all white
supremacists and so is Trump and so is
everybody else this this reminds me when
we're when the right is looking about
how to respond to this it makes me think
you know when you're in middle school or
high school everyone's giving each other
or the break in each
Coolio's you know they're giving each
other a hard time busting each other's
chops and there's sometimes at least
among guys I assume this is true among
girls to where you know you're giving it
back and forth to each other and you're
insulting one another and you can do it
in kind of good fun or it can turn a
corner and it becomes serious and it
becomes really bullying and it becomes
like you realize the other guy hates you
you're not just kidding around anymore
and I think in American politics the
right is under this eye misapprehension
that we're just kind of joking around
and look the rights as bad things about
the left which we do we call them kind
of dummies sometimes or hysterical
children and then the left says bad
things about the right but you know look
at the end of the day we're all
Americans we all get along that's not
what we're seeing here they hate us they
hate our guts they wish we were
eradicated they think that we are Nazis
they think we're the same thing as
Hitler they hate us it's not just in
good political fun back and forth they
despise us they want our shows taken off
the air they want us to leave the
country they hate us it's not the same
thing and what this means like when you
got to stand up to the bully in middle
school or high school it means you can't
just kind of make a joke about it
anymore you've got to really you got to
really take them on seriously and what
this means is that probably on the right
we need our own media matters what this
means on the right is we need to really
speak with brutal honesty about them not
in the way that you talk about a friend
and you say well I'm gonna have a little
grace I'm gonna no I don't think we can
have grace right now with the left I
think we need to speak brutally honestly
about them
what hopeless bigots they are have vile
and filled with hatred they are how
despicably they're exploiting the
not-yet cold bodies of dead americans
for their own sick shallow political
purposes it's so shameful they should
feel profound shame their parents should
feel shame for what they're doing
their parents should be deeply ashamed
of them
and they should be ashamed of themselves
and they should go and sit at home and
cry and think about what terrible
actions they've undertaken and what
terrible people they've become and then
they should ask forgiveness of their God
and ask forgiveness of all of us and ask
forgiveness of the president and ask
forgiveness of Kellyanne Conway and ask
forgiveness of Mitch McConnell and ask
plead on their hands and knees if they
can be permitted back into polite civil
society it's really really disgusting
all of them the pod save America guys
saying that if you watch Fox News you're
contributing to white supremacy and mass
killings disgusting that man should not
be a Dan Pfeiffer is his name he should
not be permitted in polite society the
cannibal risa as I guess cannibals
generally shouldn't be permitted in
polite society
risa Ashland should not be permitted in
polite society
you know when bill de blasio basically
maligned all of his New York City police
officers as killers and thugs and
racists you know what they did they
didn't attack him they didn't physically
attack him they shouldn't do that they
just turned their backs on him that's
what we should do we should take a
moment after this awful temper tantrum
from the left a vile vicious temper
tantrum we should just turn our backs
not give them attention not engage with
them for a little bit just turn our
backs and like vicious teenagers when
they calm down they can come back and
ask forgiveness and maybe we can we can
show them grace we can show them grace
then we can't right now got to turn to
the right very briefly because at the
New York Post editorial board they
published a very stupid up err editorial
rather on this tragedy about guns called
ban weapons of war this could have been
written by a leftist or by someone who's
never fired a gun or even read a book
about guns in their lives it's really I
like the editorial board at the New York
Post I don't want to beat up on them but
this is just really stupid so very
briefly we'll go through it they go you
can read the whole editorial just a few
lines that stand out ban weapons of
god save us all sir people across the
nation are scared many feel like the
country is spinning out of control
they're looking to their leaders for
more than prayers America is terrified
okay good that's true we all agree but
you see what they're doing is they're
ginning this up is a purely emotional
issue so we're not talking about
statistics we're not talking about data
we're not doing that how guns actually
are operated just saying we have a lot
of feelings and now we need feelings
president Trump you're positioned to
assuage that fear on gun control you're
a pragmatic centrist someone who knows
there's a vast majority of Americans who
are not to the extreme left to right on
the issue they just want the killings to
stop so again this is just appeal to
emotion just appeal to how people are
feeling and this premise that if you ban
guns or certain guns the killings will
stop the Second Amendment leaves ample
room for regulating gun rights just as
every other constitutional right has
limits yeah that's true we do regulate
gun rights
the New York Post doesn't mention that
we have an estimated 20,000 gun laws on
the books at the state municipal and
federal level
we actually don't know how many gun was
there are because we have a federalist
system federal system so there are a lot
of different laws everywhere but it's
been estimated for about 50 years that
we have around 20,000 laws Trump is
sneered and others for being afraid of
the NRA when it comes to passing
common-sense gun laws what's a
common-sense gun law you tell me I don't
know he'd surely have rather had
Congress pass a law banning bumped
stocks although his administration got
it done eventually through executive
actions yeah right he banned bum stocks
and that didn't do anything to reduce
any mass shootings whatsoever
New York Post threw this one little bit
little fact that they managed to sneak
in and this emotivist editorial they
undermine their premise Trump did ban
bump stocks it was a stupid decision to
do that at the time it didn't have any
bearing in the reality of crime or gun
deaths and and guess what we had to mass
shootings two days in a row over the
weekend didn't do anything but I'm sure
this this totally emotionally driven
piece of gun control I'm sure this will
do something now right come up with
answers now beginning with the return of
an assault weapons ban by the way
assault weapons not a real category of
gun
there are assault rifles those are fully
automatic rifles those are virtually
banned in the United
States more or less totally banned
assault weapons is a term invented in
the 1980s to confuse people who don't
know anything about guns they just refer
to any sort of regular old rifle where
you pull the trigger once and one round
is fired and they have a few cosmetic
features that make them look a little
scarier but functionally speaking
they're the same as just about any rifle
the New York Post uses that meaningless
language that deceptive language we know
that label doesn't actually describe a
clear class of guns ok then why'd you
use the label and that some studies show
that the last ban in effect from 1994 to
2004 had a limited impact yep also true
but that simply means the next man
should be better written with a clear
definition focused on factors like
firepower rate of fire muzzle velocity
etc not on cosmetic features now this
shows there just total ignorance of guns
because there is no difference in the
rate of fire or the muzzle velocity of
this one class that they're calling
assault weapons and other types of
rifles they're just they're just rifles
the cosmetic feature is the thing the
Supreme Court has ruled that the Second
Amendment protects the right to own guns
in common use but that doesn't cover
semi-automatic weapons regularly used
only in mass shootings yes it does
because they're not regularly used only
in mass shootings ar-15s are like the
most popular gun in America and they're
popular because there are pretty good
guns I mean they're they're light
they're they're good rifles but they're
just guns they are they are the common
weapon again it just belies this
ignorance about guns that usually we see
on the left but occasionally we see on
the right guns don't kill people people
do says the cliche it's not a cliche
it's a fact but the twisted and the evil
can kill a lot more when handed a murder
machine and what a murder machine that
were to a ar-15s or murder machines but
pistols or what lollypops pistols are
cotton candy no actually actually if you
look at the data handguns kill over 22
times as many people each year as all
rifles not just the murder machine
assault weapon whatever fake term you
want to use all rifles put together
including ar-15s and any other assault
weapon you want to include in there 22
times more people
handguns killed many more people over
that 48-hour period where we saw the
shootings in El Paso and Dayton Ohio
then-wife rifles of any kind including
assault weapons quote-unquote our
founding fathers gave us the right to
bear arm in a time of muskets again not
true first of all I love this idea that
our founding fathers are these idiots
who just they could construct the
greatest republic in the history of
mankind there were some of the most
learned people who lived in history and
yet they couldn't suspect that whom
maybe guns which have been improving in
technology for the past hundreds of
years will continue to improve as in
technology also they we didn't just have
muskets at that time we had the Kentucky
rifle as early as the early 18th century
some powerful gun a murder machine a
weapon of war we had weapons of war and
weapons of war particularly specifically
were protected by the Second Amendment
the Second Amendment protected the
weapons that were used in the
Revolutionary War peace goes on they did
not foresee a time when a 21 year old
could kill 20 people in the span of
minutes yes they did they did they
weren't idiots contrary to this modern
belief that everyone who lived more than
five minutes ago was a total dummy and
were really smart believe it or not even
the old timey people with the powdered
wigs were not total idiots it does not
have to be this way it should not have
to be this way mr. president do
something help America live without fear
more people are killed each year by bats
hammers hands fists feet then are killed
by any kind of rifle including the ar-15
an assault weapons ban quote/unquote
would do nothing it would accomplish
nothing it would just make people feel
good and make right-wingers who are
usually pretty clear thinking but our on
occasion susceptible to emotional
emotivist arguments make them feel like
they've done something but they haven't
this is why the left always wants us to
leap into action think we can't wait we
the time is now we have to act they want
us to act before we think because when
we think we look at the numbers and we
realize this is nothing but emotional
manipulation would not really save
American lives it would
take away a cherished and inherited
right that we in this country have had
for centuries and that we inherited from
our political ancestors centuries before
that we need to defend reality
conservatives need to defend reality in
the face of this frivolous emotivism you
know that's all the left has in this
election is frivolous emotivism they
have well this is one of my favorite
things going back to the race issue you
have you have this new phrase that's
cropped up on the left do you see it in
the presidential debates it's called
pass the mic this idea that white people
shouldn't be able to say anything only
people of color should say something
they are the only ones who should have
political opinions and what's so funny
is the people who use this phrase don't
believe it themselves because the people
who use that phrase are always the white
people it's always these white liberals
saying I love passing the mic there was
a guy this got tens of thousands of
retweets and likes over the weekend this
guy Ethan Wright some young leftist guy
he tweets out attention white activists
take notice of this great tactic to help
uplift other voices and it's a video of
him with a little smug smile passing a
microphone you know if he believed it he
would actually just pass the microphone
instead of posting a tweet about how
great he is and why people should listen
to him and watch him passing the
microphone to get tens and tens of
thousands of retweets kirsten gillibrand
did this at the last presidential debate
there's a great photo of her Kamala
Harris starts speaking and she puts her
hand out and stops Kamala Harris a black
woman from speaking so that she a blonde
white woman can talk about how important
it is to not have blonde white women
speak and only have black people speak I
don't believe that it's the
responsibility of Korie and Kamala to be
the only voice that takes on these
issues of institutional racism systemic
racism in our country I think as a white
woman of privilege who is a u.s. senator
running for president United States it
is also my responsibility to lift of
those voices that aren't being listened
to and I can talk to those white women
in the suburbs that voted for Trump and
explain to them what white privilege
actually is that when their son is
walking down a street with a bag of M&Ms
in his pocket wearing a hoodie
his whiteness is what protects him from
not being shot has a car that breaks
down and he knocks on someone's door for
help and the door opens and the help is
given it's his whiteness that protects
him from being shot that is what white
privilege in America is today and so my
responsibilities to not only lift up
those stories but explain to communities
across America like I did in Youngstown
Ohio to a young mother that this is all
of our responsibilities and that
together we can make our community
stronger who better to uplift Black
Voices than a blonde white woman may be
the most Aryan looking woman ever to
walk in the face of the earth who better
I actually now might believe in white
privilege I think white privilege is
just the obliviousness to shut up
Kamala Harris and Cory Booker so that
you can ramble on for over a minute
about how terrible white privileges and
how we just need to uplift black voices
and not have white voices that you know
Eric's whoa well before he dropped out
of the race someone asked him you're
just a white guy why are you running and
he said well I'm a white guy who
understands and I'm gonna pass the mic
when when I other people have
experiences that I don't well he's
passed the mic only because his campaign
we ran out of money and support it's
it's a total lie they don't pass the mic
they want to keep the mic and then they
want to hold that mic and they want to
tell you about how much they love
passing the mic it is just a totally
empty virtue signal on race and it's
meant to gin up racial division racial
hatred and make you think that anyone to
the right of them is some racist awful
terrible bigot it's disgusting
they should feel deeply ashamed for it
and if they I fear that it's going to
tear the country apart in many ways I
mean they're their whole political
career is just ripping open old racial
wounds racial wounds that were caused by
the way by their own political party but
or mostly by their own political party
but they don't care I mean they don't
care about the country they don't like
the country they say they want to
fundamentally transform it anyway and it
looks like that process is underway
at least we should open our eyes to see
what they're doing before we go I just
have to make one point on this news
coming out of the White House the actual
news of the day instead of all this
emotivist frivolity from the left which
is that the Treasury Department is now
officially labeling China a currency
manipulator this is long overdue and I
know this is kind of a complex issue so
just to to put it in in simple terms a
lot of times the left and the
institutional right doesn't want to
acknowledge that we do have an issue on
trade we that President Trump is right
on this trade issue that we're going
into a trade war which big business and
the Chamber of Commerce hates but we're
going into it 15 years overdue we're
already in a trade war China has been
leveling this trade war against us for
years and big business basically just
wanted to turn a blind eye to prioritize
their own profits over the health of the
country in the long term fair enough
that's big business is prerogative but
it's not terribly patriotic and we've
got to do something about it China has
been illegally manipulating their
currency about 18 years ago now we
allowed China into the World Trade
Organization this was probably a mistake
we have the World Trade Organization we
have a global trade and the global trade
order in order to facilitate the
movement of goods and services around
the world and what we had been doing is
allowing smaller economies into the
World Trade Organization Japan South
Korea and because there were smaller
economies and because they were under US
military protection we had some leverage
over them so we opened up our markets
they open up their markets and if they
start violating the trade rules then we
have this leverage over them and so we
can keep things in order
when we allowed China and China had a
way way bigger population in a way way
bigger economy trillions and trillions
of dollars in their economy and over a
billion people and we allowed them in
obviously they're not under our military
protection it meant that we had no
leverage on them and they consistently
would violate trade well they would
steal our intellectual property they
would force hidden taxes on foreign
businesses really meaning US businesses
that would operate there they would
force them to use local banking partners
which was just a grift it was a total
extortion racket they spy on us they
obviously put spyware in our technology
which they're pretty
and they illegally subsidized steel and
aluminum which is in violation of the
World Trade Organization and they
manipulate their currency so the reason
they manipulate their currency and
devalue their currency is it gave them a
trade advantage over the United States
so the way this works is it went when
China is exporting lots and lots of
goods they want to keep exporting lots
and lots of goods but as the price of
the yuan their currency increases that
compromises that so what they do is they
sell off a lot of their yuan and they
buy other currencies really meaning the
dollar and they buy this dollar which
artificially and illegally devalue their
currency and allows them to keep
exporting lots of goods and not have to
import as many goods so it protects
their own companies this has cost the
United States and at least a million
jobs over the years probably more than
that maybe three million jobs or even
more this has really hurt manufacturers
in the United States and it's illegal
this is not free trade there is nothing
free or fair about it it has also
exacerbated our trade deficit we would
not have had nearly as big a trade
deficit if China had not been doing this
if we called them out for this now the
United States can't really have a
tit-for-tat here and devalue our
currency by buying more of their
currency because if we're the global
reserve currency so if we did that it
could really throw the global financial
system into chaos the long and short of
this is we have to fight back for the
long-term health of our country for the
long-term health of our economy for the
long-term health of our national
security and it's going to cause
financial trouble in the short term it
might cause a dip in GDP might cause our
stocks to drop that's the cost of
citizenship that's the cost of
nationhood politicians of both parties
when they've been honest over the last
20 years including Chuck Schumer just
recently said we need to get tough on
China we can't kick this down the road
anymore President Trump is doing this
he's taking a political hit for doing it
but it's the patriotic thing it's the
right thing to do and I hope he I hope
he doesn't go weak I hope you say stay
strong on China okay that's our show we
got a lot more to get to we'll have to
do it tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show see you then
the Michael Dole show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer
Austin Stephens editor Dany D'Amico our
audio mixer is Mike quorum inna hair and
makeup by Jesuit Elvira production
assistant NIC Sheehan the Michael Noel's
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know Donald
Trump may be rude but the main stream
left is truly appalling they used the
bodies of the innocent to push their
agenda and they demonize every point of
view that's not their own to paraphrase
the immortal final line from the film
jagged edge screw on their trash if the
New York Times won't help us find a way
to discuss our problems we'll do it
ourselves on the Andrew Klavan show I'm
Andrew Clavin